>>> I WANT THINGS TO BE GREAT
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR AND FOR
WOMEN.
FOR US TO BE ABLE RUSSISHOW UP
WORK AND BE APPRECIATED FOR THAT
WORK.
IF I CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THAT, AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE EASY,
THERE'S GOING TO BE LOTS OF
CHALLENGES, YOU KNOW.
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE
FRUSTRATING DAYS.
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE TIMES I
CRY.
I DON'T MIND CRYING, BY THE WAY.
BUT I'M HOPEFUL.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT'S REALLY
WHAT'S DRIVING ME, I'M HOPEFUL.
I CAN SEE THE LARGER PICTURE.
>> THAT WAS MARKETING EXECUTIVE
BOZOMA SAINT JOHN IN 21st
CENTURY -- IN 2017.
SHE SAYS, QUOTE, THERE IS
NOTHING MORE BAD ASS THAN BEING
YOURSELF.
SHE'S THE CHIEF MARKETING
OFFICER AT NETFLIX AND OVERSEES
MORE THAN $2 MILLION TO PROMOTE
SHOWS AND FILMS IN MORE THAN 30
COUNTRIES.
SHE PREVIOUSLY WORKED AS AN
EXECUTIVE AT COMPANIES YOU MIGHT
HAVE HEARD OF -- UBER, APPLE,
AND PEPSI TO NAME A FEW.
BOZOMA SAINT JOHN JOHNS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING!
>> GOOD MORNING, DREW.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I HAVE
BEEN WANTING TO SPEAK WITH YOU
-- YOU ARE ONE OF THE FIRST
PEOPLE I TALKED ABOUT ACTUALLY
WHEN WE LAUNCHED OUR SHOW, "THE
DREW BARRYMORE SHOW."
I DID A LITTLE FEATURE ON YOU.
I'VE BEEN A TOTAL FAN OF YOURS,
AND YOU KNOW, YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN
THIS $2 BILLION BUDGET, BUT I
WAS STUDYING AND SAW THAT YOU
WORKED AT SPIKE DDB WHICH IS A
NOD TO DOYLE DANE BURNBACK, THE
FAMOUS ADVERTISING AGENCY.
AND THAT YOU GUYS TALKED ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF MARKETING AND
MESSAGING.
WHY IS THAT SO IMPORTANT?
>> WELL, MESSAGING IS ALL ABOUT
STORYTELLING.
YOU KNOW, I LEARNED THAT LESSON
VERY EARLY ON.
I WAS PROBABLY 12 WHEN MY FAMILY
MOVED FROM GHANA, WHERE WE'RE
ORIGINALLY FROM, TO COLORADO
SPRINGS, COLORADO.
AND REALLY THE ONLY THING THAT
CONNECTED ME TO MY CLASSMATES
BECAUSE SO MANY THINGS SEPARATED
US, YOU KNOW, RACE, CULTURE,
LANGUAGE, FOOD, SO MANY THINGS.
THE ONLY THING THAT REALLY
CONNECTED US WAS POP CULTURE.
>> UH-HUH.
>> THE STORYTELLING, THE
CONNECTIONS OF MUSIC AND FASHION
AND SPORTS.
THE THINGS THAT WERE HAPPENING
CONSTANTLY.
THAT'S FOR ME WHERE IT STARTED.
THAT'S WHY I LOVER MARKETING
BECAUSE IT'S ALL ABOUT
STORYTELLING AND MAKING
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT OTHERWISE SEE THEIR
CONNECTIONS.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THAT IS IT
PARLAYS ONE OF THE REASONS I'VE
BEEN SUCH A FAN OF YEARS.
I, TOO, LOP POP CULTURE, IT
ABSOLUTELY CONNECTS US.
WHEN YOU GO INTO ALL OF THESE
INCREDIBLE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
SUCH POWER, SO MUCH MONEY BEHIND
THEM, SO MUCH ABILITY TO GET
THESE STORYTELLING OUT IN
COMMERCIALS AND AD BUYS, LIKE I
WANT TO KNOW AS THE QUEEN OF
COOL, LIKE WHERE DO YOU GET YOUR
NEWS?
WHAT SITES DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE WATCHING?
WHERE SHOULD WE BE TURNING TO BE
ON TOP OF AND AHEAD OF THE CURVE
ON POP CULTURE?
>> WELL, THE FIRST TRICK, DREW,
IS TO BE ENDLESSLY CURIOUS.
YOU KNOW, JUST TO BE CURIOUS
ABOUT PEOPLE, ABOUT THEIR
STORIES, ABOUT WHERE THEY ARE
FROM, WHAT THEIR BACKGROUNDS
ARE.
AND WHEN YOU'RE CURIOUS ABOUT
PEOPLE, YOU'LL BE SURPRISED BY
HOW MUCH YOU'LL LEARN JUST IN
THE SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
I CAN PICK UP THINGS FROM
ANYWHERE.
YOU KNOW, FROM THE GROCERY STORE
TO TWITTER TO EAR HUSTLING IN
THE AIRPORT -- WELL, BACK WHEN
WE COULD ALL TRAVEL.
TO JUST ABOUT ANYPLACE.
IT'S REALLY JUST ABOUT BEING
CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE ARE
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND WHY
THEY'RE DOING THINGS.
YOU KNOW, I'M PROBABLY ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT IF YOU EVER
MEET AT A COCKTAIL PARTY OR
SOMEPLACE WHERE WE'VE NEVER MET,
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO BE ASKING
YOU A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY
IT IS THAT YOU ARE THE WAY THAT
YOU ARE.
>> NO, NO.
WHEN YOU WALK IN A ROOM, PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW WHO IS SHE, AND LET
ME TALK TO HER.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A BIG
CHAMPION OF WOMEN.
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE A BIG
CHAMPION OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> YES.
>> YET, THERE IS STILL SO MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE IN ALL AREAS, IN
ALL OF THOSE AREAS.
AND CERTAINLY IN THE COMPANIES.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE DONE
IN YOUR COMPANY IN PARTICULAR,
ADVICE FOR OTHERS?
>> OH, GAYLE, WELL, THIS IS THE
QUESTION THAT I LOVE MOST,
RIGHT, ABOUT HOW WE CAN CONTINUE
TO FURTHER NOT JUST DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION BUT WHAT ROLE WE
ALL PLAY IN IT.
SOMETIMES I THINK WE LET THE
RESPONSIBILITY GO TO SOMEONE
ELSE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S THE GOVERNMENT OR
IT'S THE CEO OR -- OR SOMEBODY
ELSE WHO CAN MAKE A POLICY TO
MAKE US CHANGE THE WAY THAT WE
BEHAVE.
AND THAT IS WHY I WANT US ALL TO
REALIZE THAT ACTUALLY THE
POWER'S WITHIN US.
THAT'S NOT JUST SOME TRITE
STATEMENT.
IT'S TRUE.
IT'S REALLY TRUE.
IT'S LIKE HOW DO YOU BEHAVE?
WHO ARE YOUR FRIENDS?
WHO DO YOU GET YOUR INFORMATION
FROM?
WHO ARE YOU CONNECTED TO?
AND THEN IF WE UNDERSTAND WHO WE
ARE AND HOW WE BEHAVE AND THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE GETTING
AND THE WAY THAT WE TREAT OTHER
PEOPLE, THEN WE SHOW UP IN OUR
FULL SELVES IN EVERY SITUATION.
SO EVEN FOR ME IT'S LIKE
REGARDLESS OF THE COMPANY THAT I
WORK FOR OR THE ENVIRONMENTS I'M
IN, I'M COMING IN AS MY FULL
SELF.
YOU KNOW, FULLY INFORMED WITH
OPINIONS OF OTHER PEOPLE AND HOW
THEY ARE INTERACTING IN THE
WORLD.
AND HOPEFULLY IT'S THE WAY THAT
I'M ABLE THEN TO PUT THOSE
OPINIONS INTO MY WORK.
AND IT'S THE WAY THAT I HOPE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ALSO BEHAVING
AND, THEREFORE, CREATING WORK
THAT SERVES OUR WORLD.
>> IT'S ANTHONY.
YOU'VE CREATED A SERIES OF
BAD-ASS WORKSHOPS, I LOVE THIS
NAME, TO HELP PEOPLE FIND THEIR
GREATEST SELF.
WHAT'S YOUR -- TO YOU, WHAT DOES
BEING A BAD ASS MEAN?
>> OH, BEING A BAD ASS MEANS
THAT YOU ARE COMPLETELY IN FULL
CONTROL OF WHO YOU ARE, FLAWS
AND ALL.
YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T MEAN
PERFECTION.
>> FLAWS AND ALL.
>> IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU ARE
BIGGER OR BETTER THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
IT'S JUST THAT YOU FULLY VALUE
WHO YOU ARE AND WHAT YOU
CONTRIBUTE.
AND FOR ME, THAT'S WHAT'S TRUE.
YOU KNOW, I -- I WALK AROUND THE
PLANET KNOWING THAT LIKE THE
LESSON IN BIOLOGY, YOU KNOW,
IT'S LIKE -- IF ONE MOLECULE
ENTERS A MATTER, THE WHOLE
MATTER CHANGES.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M THAT MOLECULE THAT
CHANGES MATTER.
>> I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
AWARDS SHOWS.
WITHIN THE PANDEMIC, I THINK WE
HAD A REAL LIFT OF THE VEIL OF
AWARDS SHOWS.
THEY'RE NOT AS FANCY, THEY'RE
MORE AT HOME.
WE'VE HAD THE OSCARS, YOU KNOW,
SO WHITE, THE -- THE HFPA, YOU
KNOW, CAME OUT AND SAID WE WANT
TO STOP WORKING WITH YOU GUYS
UNTIL YOU GUYS CHANGE -- YOU ARE
A FIXER.
YOU COME IN AND YOU LITERALLY
FIX IT.
IS THERE A WAY TO COME IN AND
FIX AWARDS SHOWS?
WHEN I WATCHED THE NFL DRAFT,
THERE'S JUST SUCH EXCITEMENT.
>> THE ENERGY'S GREAT.
>> HOW CAN WE GET BEHIND AWARDS
SHOWS AGAIN?
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE OFF
TRACK RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH.
YES.
WELL, I AGREE WITH THAT.
I MEAN, I WAS REALLY SO PROUD OF
NETFLIX, OBVIOUSLY, AND TED WITH
THE LETTER TO THE HFPA BECAUSE
FOR US IT'S REALLY ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE HOLDING
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE AND
EVERYONE WE WORK WITH
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU KNOW, THE CHANGE DOESN'T
HAPPEN JUST BECAUSE WE SAY WE
WANT IT TO CHANGE.
WE HAVE TO HOLD EVERYONE
ACCOUNTABLE, THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY, AND THEN FURTHER THAN
THAT, ALL OF CORPORATIONS.
YOU KNOW, SO I -- I DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S A POSSIBILITY FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO SEE THE CHANGE
THAT WE WANT.
BUT AGAIN, I WON'T LEAVE IT TO
POLICYMAKERS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S ALL OF US.
IT'S THE FOLKS WHO WATCH THE
SHOWS, IT IS THE FOLKS WHO GO TO
MOVIES, IT IS THE PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT --
>> I LIKE THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING --
>> WE HAVE GOT TO SAY SOMETHING.
>> I LIKE THE POINT WHERE YOU
SAY WE ALL PLAY A PART.
THIS STUCK OUT TO ME ABOUT YOU,
YOU SAID YOU HAVE RECLAIMED THE,
QUOTE, ANGRY BLACK WOMAN.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> WELL, THERE'S QUITE A
STEREOTYPE.
>> YOU'RE TALKING TO A BLACK
WOMAN RIGHT NOW.
GO AHEAD.
>> OKAY.
EXACTLY.
WELL, THE STEREOTYPE EXISTS THAT
IF YOU'RE A BLACK WOMAN -- OR
LET'S CALL IT A WOMAN OF COLOR
-- YOU KNOW, WHO EXPRESSES ANY
KIND OF PASSION, EXCITEMENT,
SOMETIMES AGGRESSIVENESS, YOU
KNOW, IN YOUR OPINION, THAT YOU
ARE HYSTERICAL AND THEN THE
WORST NAME -- ANGRY.
AND TISOMETIMES THE "B" WORD.
IN LIGHT OF LAST SUMMER AND WITH
THE MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD AND
WE SAW ALL OF THE RACIAL
RECKONING THAT WAS HAPPENING
ACROSS AMERICA, AND REALLY
ACROSS THE WORLD, I WANTED TO
RECLAIM IT.
I WAS LIKE, HELL, YEAH, I'M
ANGRY.
I'M MAD.
YOU SHOULD BE, TOO.
>> I HEAR YOU.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT, YOU GOT TO FIX
IT.
>> I HEAR YOU BOZOMA SAINT JOHN.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR NEW
ROLE